[MUSIC]
My days as an assistant principal began
by the flagpole, welcoming students
to school, like Roberto with his
rattail and ninja turtle backpack.
He was just one of those
kiddos who made me smile.
I'd greet students with high-fives,
fist bumps and,
as Roberto taught me, the super
cool sliding handshake fist bump.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Then, I would usher them through
the doors, thinking that once we were all
inside, we could get down to the business
of learning and growing up,
unaffected by the outside world.
I became a teacher because
of students like Roberto.
I knew that education could open doors.
I learned, however,
that a community can change a school.
Today, I want to introduce you
to Mitchell Middle School.
I want to introduce you to Mitchell
because it introduced me to challenges
I still grapple with.
It transformed my understanding
of community and education.
To get to Mitchell, you go to
the trendiest neighborhood in town,
then head just four blocks to the east.
The spin studios and
breweries quickly shift to small homes,
vacant lots and
the dollar tree inside the building.
Our students, like most teenagers,
grappled with their first essay,
saying Selena Gomez at break.
Outside the school, they helped care for
little siblings worried about
the deportation of a family member.
Struggled sometimes to find food
in an area with no grocery store.
My kids carry the trauma and
uncertainties with them that I,
the adult, had never known.
Mitchell taught me that the brick walls of
a school building do not make a fortress.
Schools and their surrounding
communities are constantly shaping and
being shaped by one another.
With Mitchell as our model,
let's zoom out.
Where is the opportunity
gap in American schools?
We know that if high school
graduates who grew up in poverty,
14% only will graduate
college within eight years.
We know that third-grade reading
scores are used to predict
future needed prison capacity.
Now, let's zoom in to our current home,
Palo Alto.
The green represents wealth.
At Duveneck Elementary school,
just 6% of students qualify for free and
reduced lunch,
a measure of financial need.
Students here are 3.6 years above
the national average and they're learning.
At Los Robles-Ronald McNair Academy,
just one mile away,
93% of students qualify for
free reduced lunch.
Students here?
Students here are nearly three grade
levels below the national average.
How is this possible that there is a sixth
grade level gap in our one ZIP code?
Let's talk about funding.
When I was a teacher, a rainy day could
mean that I taught verbs while maneuvering
around a bucket to catch water
dripping through the roof.
Recess was on a cracked parking lot.
These were the physical representations
of a system that provide the fortunate
with boundless opportunity, while
leaving behind far too many children.
Across the country, school districts
that serve mostly minority children
receive $23 billion less than
majority white districts.
In wealthy areas like Palo Alto, property
taxes provide an infusion of money.
Parent-teacher associations are powerful
and can bring in further funding.
We must acknowledge these facts and
their implications.
At the same time,
they're more than just numbers.
We the people must get
to know one another.
At Mitchell, our students brought
the staff homemade tamales.
Sharp around the eighth grade formal,
arrived at 6.30 in the morning before
at work to conference with teachers.
They cared deeply, but they did not always
have the pocket book to meet every need.
Our time for school is ending soon.
But our connection to schools is not.
Today, students are your future
colleagues, employees, and fellow voters.
The issues in public education are,
yes, messy and bureaucratic.
I cannot say they are easy to fix.
I can say they are not permanent.
Too often, glitzy innovations like
a new education technology tool,
dominate our attention.
These ideas are great, and they can help.
But the first step is far simpler,
and rooted in our daily lives.
Figure out how you connect to
the community around you, and respond.
Mitchell taught me three ways
that we can begin this process.
By thinking about our place,
our resources, and our influence.
Let's start with where you are,
your place.
I challenge you to expand
the definition of your community.
Look beyond your familiar blocks.
Learn about the area,
get to know schools like Mitchell.
If you have children,
send them to public school, don't opt out.
If you want your kid to be successful in
the real world, send them to school there.
They will benefit from getting to
learn from their classmates, and
being part of that community,
their community.
Secondly, the most tangible, resources.
Since the majority of public school
funding comes from property taxes,
schools and property poor neighborhoods
need further access to resources.
Find a school near you that would benefit
from whatever you can contribute.
That might mean corporate donations or
spare office chairs.
Lastly, how can we use our influence?
The good news is that education
is a unicorn, one of those
rare areas where members of both
political parties can find agreement.
Across the country, nearly every
school board is publicly elected.
Yet not even one in ten people vote
in local school board elections.
Participate to support candidates who
extend equitable funding to schools and
programs.
I would love if every single
one of you left here today and
decided to become a middle school teacher.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I get it, this is business school.
No matter where you go
after you leave Stanford,
remember that the brick walls
of a school are not a fortress.
Our communities will shape our schools and
our schools will shape our communities.
How will you contribute?
Roberto is now in eighth grade.
I do not know how his story will unfold.
I do know the statistics tell me he
has a 60% of graduating high school.
He is more likely to become incarcerated
than to graduate from college.
But I have hope for Roberto.
I have hope because of
students like Michael,
Michael was in my first year of teaching.
He was one of those kids who carried
a second-hand briefcase to school
in sixth grade.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Fortunately, Michael was accepted to
a local scholarship and mentorship program
that supported him through high school.
Michael is now a freshman at Brown,
majoring in neuroscience and education,
because, as Michael told me, he wants to
return and give back to his community.
Michael is the young man he is
today because of his hard work,
personal gifts and the support of
a community that carried him forward.
With our collective efforts,
let's make students like Michael
no longer the exception.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]